hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey and I'm Paula Demi
we got Paula Deming with us on the
channel you don't really watch Family
Guy right don't really watch well you
know what it doesn't matter because I
think they're hilarious and we're gonna
do it try not to laugh Family Guy
edition alright I will try not to laugh
and honestly Family Guy is one of the
few that I actually struggled with when
it comes to these try not to laughs you
guys can follow Paula Demi on Instagram
at what Taliban DITA is my Instagram
watch a board game stuff on there you
can follow me on Twitter it's my name
Paula Deming lots of fun things there
you can find my youtube channel also
Paula Jimmy and I'm doing board game
comedy sketches on my YouTube and some
video game Let's Plays and the fan
theory TV oh my god also please watch me
watch Doctor Who on fan Theory TV it's
great stuff Paula I'm happy you're here
you're real delight but listen before we
hop into this I would like to give a
special shout out to today's video
sponsor and that is for Vikings war of
clans people you might have heard other
people shout them out before there's a
reason why because they are great if
you've yet to play Vikings war of clans
it's a strategy based game in the
tradition of some of your favorite RPG
of the 90s leave some of them John stuff
like Diablo old-school fallout dragon
warrior pretty much think of an RPG you
loved in the 90s and while those games
were certainly addictive war of clans is
even more so thanks to its network of
over 20 million online players that's
right you and your friends can shape the
way the game evolves by fighting over
resources forging new alliances and
competing in live events plus plus
paulla plus what the game is totally
free what so if you're looking for a new
game and you want to help support our
channel you can do so by downloading
Vikings for free on iOS and Android
using our link in the description box
and when you do you'll receive a bonus
of 200 gold coins plus a protective
shield to get your journey started our
link description box try it today
everyone that includes you Paula yeah
okay
are you downloading where's my I'll get
my phone I'll do it right now right
after the react look in the description
ha ha good other paw no other paw no we
practice this you could make me look bad
in front of the other guys other paw
finally you know this actually reminds
me of a quote by Milton shut look so uh
you got you got my money huh oh yeah
I'll pay you soon
yeah well have the money by tomorrow and
there will be any problems huh
yeah $24 why what what happens in 24
hours yeah I don't know what psychic man
I'm just saying it would probably be
better for everybody if you had the
money tomorrow yeah all right I'll see
what I can do
sweet sweet great Oh how's everything
else goin good alright no luck
see you later don't forget now you're
not gonna forget
Stewie hey yeah so uh it's been 24 hours
got my money
oh I you know what just give me till
next Friday I'll have it for you that's
funny I could have sworn I said he had
it today yeah I don't have it sorry oh
all right then
mmm that's cool do J
you go till five o'clock you hear me you
got till five o'clock your freaking
psychopath
clean yourself up what the hell happened
to you
I uh fell down the stairs oh you should
be more careful more fake mustaches huh
unless you pay for that fake mustache
$2.99
I want my money man Sooey
listen this is crazy you got oh my god
all right let's go on the bench
private week even though right ready to
start a new life in England I've got my
money your wounds have healed up nicely
what do you say we let bygones be
bygones hmm you shot me in both my knees
then lit me on fire piss off all right
all right I tell you what you get okay
I'm not gonna tell you my husband left
me always you know what I mean
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
funny get your fat ass back this is even
morning tension at time I forgot how to
sit down gets me Jay Gatsby
it was clearly playing with himself
through his pocket but I pretended not
to see Oh welcome to my party names
Gatsby who the meet you old sport yeah
just a wave is fine all right I'm gonna
exit while this is weakly checking out
the hot chick by the door mr. Sheldon oh
my god I'm saved
let's get out of here before Stewie gets
back no that's the Ross Dress for Less
the Marshalls is down here this is one
of them to Marshalls malls Tina I know
what you're doing
knock it off fine but you can't stop the
girls in my day you Rock mr. gene right
wine coolers mr. cheese you sure we
don't have to wear clothing here mr. G
let's just do that
[Music]
before the carnival dad saw a one-act
play Oh get that down to the end of the
summer we just do jet ski rental oh it's
over there I guess that's what it would
look like if you were a human and you
had the burches smile
yeah he's reminding me of like a horror
movie villain and I just can't please
whose face would go back but it it
didn't maybe because it landed on a
freeze frame in just gonna be my
nightmares later now this is part of
they try not to laugh it's a 10-hour
supercut of justice event that moment
with quagmire and Lois is sister some
things John finds himself in on a weekly
basis it's like yup John's is slaying
girls left and right and I'm like oh I
wish I wish I could be that guy but
there's a reason why John can just do
things like that and still gets woman me
I mean I care too much you know that's
why I'm the friendzone kind of guy
ain't that right Paula there is no such
thing as the friendzone okay
okay yeah that's a half of that [ __ ]
it's gonna joke laughs and then I really
left that bit of Brian Owings Stewie 50
bucks is one of my favorite family there
there's a few Family Guy Pizza always
make me laugh every time and that is one
of them right there so it's one of the
beauty of like that's a beautiful thing
of Family Guy to me is one of those
types of is just so physically
absurd over something so mundane yet
takes it to the next degrees if he owes
him like a million dollars why but the
thing that tickled me the most I mean it
the hardest for me to laugh in that bit
was when he gets out of the bath and
then wraps a towel dog like his normal
everyday like how he goes about on the
show he doesn't have pants yeah so why
did he need a towel that well I don't
know why Seth MacFarlane loves classic
cartoons like he often references like
the Disney ones or even Charlie Brown
and so I imagine that in some ways
that's like a little nod to Donald Duck
which I really do appreciate -
appreciate that a hell of a lot shot off
that guy's son is me the part and you
saw like the inside of it yeah like that
are violent bits that family I can get
away with that just wouldn't work in
real life you just can't like if they
were alive action comedies it would just
be disturbing and wouldn't be funny well
although I would like to kind of perform
some of those bits on the garbage people
outside right now
oh yeah who'd love to constantly do this
whenever we're filming they should work
around our hours right we shouldn't work
around theirs yes so if you work for the
city and you're watching this get it get
in touch all right
right now he's watching Tyrone Magnus
reaction videos yeah as he's just
pulling levers with no regard to the
people around him or waiting in that
alley for that truck to hurry up because
they made the wrong turn into that alley
and have no way of going around that
many times can never park in the garage
you know rough life I have a very rough
life as an American male I can tell you
I have it the worst I also love Peters
touching them self fantasies he applies
logic to it you're not cops right oh my
gosh that was oh that's how I do it too
was appropriate yeah I Bhosle found
myself sitting there going in the
context of this cartoon fantasy holder
all these
I feel uncomfortable should I or is this
actually legally okay in some way I mean
this is just a great test of your moral
compass yeah Family Guy does they test
you they test you I felt good and moral
during that yeah yeah speaking of good
and moral to herbert the pervert popped
up for like a half second in this which
was like especially in high schools like
everyone's favorite Family Guy
characters so for me personally I was
happy to see him show back up get your
fat ass back here yeah yeah man he's my
personal favorite - the one I identify
with the most oh yeah guys subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell follow Paulo on all that social
media [ __ ] she talked about earlier and
fan theory TV yeah and last but not
least Vikings war of clans yeah download
it today people link in description box